problema número 3 sea fx igual a la 2x y
sea r la región en el primer cuadrante
acotada por la gráfica de f los ejes
coordenadas y la recta vertical x igual
acá aquí tenemos la gráfica en el
documento original se encuentra arriba
del texto pero aquí la pusimos nosotros
para no desperdiciar el espacio en esta
pantalla aquí tenemos la gráfica de fx
aquí tenemos la recta x igual acá está
encierra la región en el primer
cuadrante la región r de tal manera que
ésta es nuestra región r entonces que
nos piden nos dicen que acá es mayor que
0 y la región se muestra en esta figura
bien inciso a escribe pero no evalúe es
una expresión que incluya un integral
para obtener el perímetro el perímetro
de r en términos de k muy bien para
obtener el perímetro de rd necesitamos
obtener la longitud de los límites y el
más difícil es la longitud de esta
función desde este punto aquí
hasta este punto acá lo que voy a hacer
aquí es nuevamente deducir la fórmula
para la longitud de arco diego si vas a
tomar el examen a p siempre es bueno que
memorice la fórmula de longitud de arco
aunque siempre recomendable poderla
deducir sobre todo si tienes 35 años y
no tienes un libro de cálculo a la mano
es recomendable saberla deducir así es
que reduzcamos la nuevamente supongamos
que hacemos un zoom en la curva hacemos
un zoom sobre este sector en la curva
vamos a poner aquí este es el zoom sobre
la curva y lo que podemos hacer aquí
para obtener la longitud de arco es lo
mismo que hicimos cuando definimos
paramétrica mente la función lo que fue
en la primera parte de este examen ap
sólo que en esta ocasión al no estar
definida paramétrica mente lo haremos en
términos de xy si es que tomando esta
distancia aquí este es un pequeño cambio
en x le llamaremos de equis y este de
aquí va a ser un pequeño cambio en y al
cual le llamaremos de g
sabemos que la derivada de con respecto
a x de jane de x éste es igual a efe
prima de x no podemos suponer que
multiplicando ambos lados por de x
obtendríamos de igual a efe prima de x
de x
de y entonces es igual a f prima de x de
x y para un pequeño cambio en xy para un
pequeño cambio en y podemos aproximar la
longitud de este segmento usando el
teorema de pitágoras y si el segmento lo
suficientemente pequeño la longitud de
esta curva está directamente dada por el
tema de pitágoras toda la longitud del
segmento la calculamos como la raíz de
de x cuadrada más de y cuadrada
aquí tenemos de jacques f prima de x de
x entonces la longitud de este pequeño
segmento de curva va a estar dada por la
raíz
x cuadrada
más de jay que se prima de x de x
elevado al cuadrado que sería f prima de
x al cuadrado fort de x al cuadrado
lo único que hice fue elevar de iu al
cuadrado déjame extender este signo del
radical aquí y así al igual que hicimos
cuando teníamos efe definida de forma
paramétrica vamos a factorizar de x
cuadrada entonces esta expresión va a
ser igual a
a raíz de si factor izamos de x cuadrada
en este término tenemos uno más y
factorizar de x cual en el segundo
término tenemos fx elevada al cuadrado y
el de x cuadra que hemos factor izado lo
sacamos de la raíz y tendremos aquí el
factor de x así es que esta base la
longitud de este pequeñísimo arco un
arco infinitesimal longitud que
podríamos llamar d arc y esencialmente
lo que queremos hacer es sumar todas
esas pequeñas longitudes entonces lo que
vamos a calcular ahora es la suma desde
que x vale cero hasta que x vale acá y
aquí estamos integrando con respecto a x
si es que esta longitud de arco que
tenemos aquí déjame escribir que lo que
no están viendo calcular nos están
viendo calcular el perímetro de r
el prendimiento de r que es igual a esto
es igual a esta integral la integral de
0 acá
de la raíz
de uno más efe prima de x al cuadrado y
que es f prima de x f x es igual ayala
2x entonces f prima de x es 2
a la 2 x la derivada de 2x es 2 y la
derivada de a la 2x con respecto a 2 x
es a la 2 x tenemos entonces 12 a la 2x
que queremos elevar al cuadrado éste esp
prima de x que queremos elevar al
cuadrado entonces sería 4 a la 4 x así
que esta parte claro con dx es de la
longitud de este arco y es la parte
difícil y tenemos que obtener el resto
del perímetro ahora esta parte de aquí
en esta parte del perímetro es uno de
longitud desde cero a uno sería más uno
tenemos luego esta porción sobre el eje
x es una porción de longitud que más acá
y finalmente tenemos esta altura esta
altura que tiene longitud
efe de acá que sería a la 2 que sería
más que a la 2 acá
acabamos encontramos el perímetro de r
no tenemos que evaluar hemos terminado